welcome to deep learning tutorial my
name is Richard Kirchner with the simply
learned team that's WWMT learned comm
get certified get ahead what's in it for
you we're gonna go over applications of
deep learning what is deep learning
why is deep learning important what are
neural networks the activation function
in our neural network the cost function
that comes in for processing our neural
networks
how did neural networks work deep
learning platforms and then we'll do
introduction to tensor flow and a use
case implementation using tensor flow so
you can see how it works and get some
hands-on so start off with the
applications of deep learning deep
learning helps us make predictions about
the rain earthquakes tsunamis etc
allowing us to take the required
precautions with deep learning machines
can comprehend speech and provide the
required output deep learning enables a
machine to recognize people and objects
in the images fed to it and with deep
learning advertisers can leverage data
to perform real-time bidding and
targeted displays advertising and these
are just a small sample of the myriad of
different uses for deep learning today
so what is a deep learning deep learning
is a subfield of machine learning that
deals with algorithms inspired by the
structure and function of the brain and
we look at this we have the larger
category which is artificial
intelligence very generic comprehensive
ideal and in there we have machine
learning and then a subcategory of
machine learning is deep learning so
when we talk about artificial
intelligence this is the ability of a
machine to imitate intelligent human
behavior so when we look at something
can it solve a problem the way humans do
can we take it to that next level so
it's just not repeating some kind of
simple output that we programmed it to
do can it actually start imitating human
intelligence and we look at machine
learning we have the application of AI
that allows a system to automatically
learn and improve from experience so
machine learning the most basic machine
learning is your linear regression model
you put a bunch of dots
on the graph and you draw a line through
them and you have a guess of what x and
y are based on where what X is you can
guess what Y is and finally we have our
deep learning application of machine
learning that uses complex algorithms
and deep neural nets to train a model
why is deep learning important it works
with unstructured data machine learning
works only with large sets of structured
and semi-structured data while deep
learning can work with both structured
and unstructured data handles complex
operations deep learning algorithms can
perform complex operations easily while
machine learning algorithms cannot
feature extraction machine learning
algorithms use labeled sample data to
extract patterns while deep learning
accept large volumes of data as input
analyze the input to extract features
out of an object achieve best
performance performance of machine
learning algorithms decreases as the
amount of data increases so to maintain
the performance of the model we need
deep learning and this is always a
challenge of when do you go from machine
learning doing linear regression or
other regression models to deep learning
neural networks it really centers around
both the complexity as it becomes more
and more complex or the problem becomes
harder to solve along with the amount of
data so both of those play a huge part
in deciding which would best serve your
purpose is to predict what your data is
going to do and try to predict the
outcome so what are neural networks with
deep learning a machine can be trained
to identify various shapes so here we
have a square coming in you can see
we've broken it up into the pixels and
we want the label to come out square and
if we turn the square slightly sideways
it's still a square and we want to still
say it's a square what deep learning a
machine can be trained to identify
various shapes or the different patterns
of those shapes as they be or in this
case being rotated but how is the
machine able to do this so we'll look at
a nice grid 28 by 28 784 pixels and we
look at that grid we look at each one of
those pixels as inputs so a neural
network is a system modeled on the human
brain and so we have all our inputs come
like your eyeball coming in there it has
the
in the back different input sensors
which are your cones and rods so each
one of those is an input coming in with
information and it goes into a neuron
and then it sends out a pulse so the
data is fed as an input to the neuron
the neuron processes the information
provided as an input the information is
transferred over weighted channels and
this is very central to our neural
network each one of those pulses coming
in gets a different weight and the
output is the final value predicted by
the artificial neuron in this image
we're only looking at one neuron so
remember we're liking talking about a
lot of neurons working together and
we'll look at how those fit together in
just a moment we look at one neuron so
let's just take a look at that one
neuron let's dig a little deeper so we
can get some concepts in here so we can
understand the neural network so what
exactly happens within a neuron we have
an activation function so within each
neuron the following operations are
performed the product of each input and
the weight of the channel it's passed
over is found some of the weighted
products is computed this is called the
weighted sum and a bias unique to the
neuron is added to the weighted sum you
can always look at that as if you have
an XY graph where's your Y and intercept
you know the old Euclidean geometry x or
y equals 3x plus 5 that's your plus 5 is
that bias as where does that come in and
this is a bit more complicated it's not
like 3x it's more like 3 x1 5 X 2 6 X 7
and usually you're dealing with float
numbers so it's not even it doesn't even
look like that it looks like 0.001 times
X 1.1 3 times X 2 and so on so the
numbers get a little confusing but the
concept is very straightforward we're
going to multiply the weight times a
value coming in and we're going to add
that all together plus the bias and the
final sum isn't subjected to the
particular function known as the
activation function and the most
simplest one is if it's greater than 0
it's 1 if it's less than 0 at 0 they
usually use a lot of different there's a
lot of other functions that are more
reliable than that one but that one
gives you the most basic understanding
of what you're looking at zero or one
coming out in most cases you actually
have a value coming out and in some
cases we use like a tangent wave
that there can be a value between 0 and
1 but it might be it tends to shoot
right up to 1 rather quickly but you
know those are things you can fine-tune
in your neural network as you start
getting to the solution let's keep in to
the generals here and let's see what's
the next step we're gonna look at the
cost function and this is so important
in understanding how the current neural
networks that we're working with are
able to learn things so we end up with a
cost value the cost value is the
difference between the neural nets
predicted output and the actual output
from a set of labeled training data the
least cost value is obtained by making
adjustments to the weights and biases
iteratively throughout the training
process and when you think about this
we're not just sending one set of
numbers through we're sending all kinds
of data in here so you might have a
hundred samples or a thousand samples
and each one of those samples comes in
and then we look at the cost for that
and we want to get that cost the minimal
the average minimal among all the
different samples so we want a general
answer on there you can see here we
denote the predicted output with a
little half triangle over it and then
the actual output is just a straight Y
on this let's learn how neural networks
work let's dig in a little deeper and
how we program them how do not net works
work exactly and this were jumping from
a single node into a larger picture so
our neural network will be trained to
identify shapes and we'll start with the
square again 28 by 28 or 784 pixels and
this is kind of the standard images we
work with a lot of times our shapes are
images of 28 by 28 pixels each pixel is
fed as an input to the neurons in the
first layer so here we have our input
layer each one of those we might flatten
that out that's the most easiest way to
process that but not the only way to
process so we flattened it out so it's
just one long array and then we have
hidden layers that improve the accuracy
of the output and you can see here we're
not looking at just one neuron we
actually have a row two hidden layers
and each layer is a row of neurons and
it is passed on from layer to layer over
waited channels each one of those inputs
is then weighted to eat sir the next
neurons in the next layer in the hidden
layer each neuron in the first hidden
layer takes
set of the inputs and processes it let's
look into what happens within the
neurons so here we have step 1 and we
can see in here where we have X 1 times
weight 1 X 2 times weight 2 plus b1
that's that top neuron up there and then
we have the next neuron down which is
step 2 and then in step 2 they denote
the with the Greek symbol Phi and Phi is
the activation function based on step 1
so it might be if it's close to 0 at 0
if it's close to 1 its 1 and it might be
a value in between it's very common
depending on what activation function
you use the results of the activation
function determine which neurons will be
activated in the following layer so you
can see here we have b1 as we looked at
with x1 and waited 1 x2 and waited 2 and
then you would compute b2 the same way
and b3 the same way and b4 and b5 and so
on so each neuron has an input from all
the input layers go into each of the
hidden layer neuron the first hidden
layer the result of the activation
function determines which neurons will
be activated in the following layer and
then that activation number goes off to
the next layer so we see here b11 b12
b13 and b 14 and the weights coming in
from b1 so let's say b1 fires and it
goes into b11 usually would see the
weights going all the way down so b2
would have their weights going into b1
and b2 were then going to be 11 b1 b2 b3
and b4 and b5 would then go into b11 and
they would have their weights depending
on what came out it might just be zero
so there's nothing coming through or it
might be as value between zero and one
and so forth for b12 b13 be 14 and be 15
and then we take those and they'll have
wait to test each one of those coming
out and they go into the final layer in
this case we have a neuron that
represents the square a neuron that
represents a circle and a neuron that
represents a triangle and just as before
the information reaching this layer is
processed after which a single neuron in
the output layer gets activated
but our input was a square what went
wrong here remember we started with the
square when we have coming out as a
circle well that's gonna be a problem
because we don't want it to tell us that
squares are circles
well our network needs to be trained
first how do we train a network the
predicted output is compared against the
actual output by calculating the cost
function remember our cost function at
the end we take whatever we said it was
going to be and what it actually is and
we just subtract those two and the most
common way used to generate the cost
function is as follows is we're gonna
take the actual value minus the
predicted value where we have Y then you
have Y with the half triangle over is
the predicted and then Y is it actual
value we subtract them we square that
value and then we divide it by 2 so it's
usually how they generate the cost
function the cost function determines
the error in prediction and reports it
back to the neural network so we're
gonna do some back propagation that's
what this is called back propagation
we're going back through the network the
other way and we're sending that error
back the other way the weights are
adjusted in order to reduce error the
network is trained with the new weights
and you can see here we have C equals
1/2 Y minus y predicted or Y actual
minus y predicted squared
once again the cost is determined and
back propagation is continued until the
cost cannot be reduced any further now
keep in mind you know if we have one
picture of a square and it goes through
we actually do just a little training we
don't change it all to match that first
one otherwise you'll have a but what
they call a bias so each of those data
goes back with our back propagation and
we'll send hundreds of samples on there
until we can get that cost as a whole
down as low as we can get so that our
average cost is very low with that it
being biased towards one specific figure
and you can see here we have our input
layer hidden layer or set up on here
similarly once we've trained it for our
square the network must also be trained
to identify circles and triangles too so
we needed sets of all of these we need
lots of squares lots of circles and lots
of triangles the weights are this
further adjusted in order to predict the
three shapes with the highest accuracy
we can now rely on our neural network to
predict the input shapes and you can see
we have a triangle coming in here and it
goes through here's our circle going
through and it's gonna light up the
circle and so on for the square so
before we dive into some hands-on let's
take a look at some deep learning
platforms the primary programming
language we're gonna look at four of
these platforms and we
start with torch the primary programming
language is Lua with an implementation
in situ
torches Python implementation is called
pi torch this is interesting because
python has become one of the leads in
data analysis so you'll almost always
see a PI torch or any one of these will
have a Python equivalent and it's slowly
spreading throughout the languages so
I'm sure there's within torch it's also
probably got a Java setup and definitely
has a C because it's primary
implementation is in C and so we have
chorus cross is a Python framework for
deep learning in USP is reusability of
code for the CPU and GPU processing we
have tensorflow tensorflow is deep
learning platform by google it was
developed in C++ and has its
implementation in Python and just a
quick highlight chorus and tensorflow
have slowly been working together so
there's a lot of things you can actually
put cross on top of tensorflow
and access tensorflow although there are
still some tools and tensorflow they
don't that crust isn't fully access but
it is a great interface for doing that
and then there's a DL for J is the first
deep learning library written for Java
and Scala it was integrated with Hadoop
and Apache spark you remember Apache
spark is written in Scala that's one of
the reasons the DL for J came about is
so that it would run on the SPARC
platform so let's take a listen to
tensor flow Google's tensor flow is
currently the most popular deep learning
library in the world it has really once
the open source said it was just amazing
how much it's spread in use and how many
tools are linked into tensor flow
tensors are vectors or matrices of n
dimensions and you can see here we have
dimension 5 we haven't dimension 4 by 5
or 5 by 4 is the case is 5 rows by 4
columns
here's 1 notice 3 by 3 by 3 and so this
is kind of nice because when you're
processing pictures there's certain
things you want to do where you want the
pixels to be next to each other that's
very important
same thing with your processing say a
movie might want a 3 by 3 grid coming in
where you have the layers of the frames
coming in to be processed
so you can see how having different
dimensions is really helpful in
analyzing certain data structures and
this is what's so great about tensors is
you can of course flatten them out like
we did earlier or you can process them
based on their location in tensor flow
all computations performed involve
tensors so everything going through is
always looked at as tensors as a matrix
or matrixes of in dimension tensor flow
architecture is as follows
pre-processing data build the model
train and estimate the model and what
we'll do is we'll go ahead and dig into
use-case cementation with tensor flow to
do that I'm actually gonna go into in
this case of you using the Anaconda
navigator and you can use either Jupiter
lab or Jupiter notebook most people are
very familiar with Jupiter notebook it's
very commonly web-based the Jupiter lab
is the next version of Jupiter notebook
and it just lets you have multiple tabs
open when you're working on it and if
you're using anaconda you'll go under
environments and you want to make sure
that you have your tensor flow installed
and you can simply we'll do this I have
it installed but you could do all do all
you can do a search and they're all for
tensor and you can see all the different
tensors it's actually installed in here
version 1.1 3.1 if it wasn't you could
check the box and then run the install
on there and bring it right in but we'll
go and start up our Jupiter lab which is
gonna open up in this case I use Google
Chrome and in our Jupiter lab or Jupiter
notebook if you're in the notebook you
only have one tab and you won't have the
added options like there's a folder and
different things you can do in the lab
that you can't do in the notebook but
everything we're gonna do you can easily
do in the notebook and you'll start up a
new project deep learning is what I'm
gonna call this and if you're not
familiar you can definitely we have some
tutorials out on the use of Jupiter
notebook and how to run it and set it up
and things like that the most basic is
we put our code in here it has a nice
display a nice interface especially for
data science I can display all kinds of
things on this page and then you can
just run this page right here there's no
code in it so it's not going to show any
thing until I put some code in there and
of course you can cut your cells and
things like that so the first thing we
want to do is we want to import our
tools now if you haven't remember you
install tensorflow and we'll also use
pandas pandas is a nice database setup
and that again is underneath your
environment and you can see here your
whatever you're working on I simply
learned setup I've installed tensor flow
and pandas in here and I'll simply go up
here and run this not gonna see anything
so we've just imported those into our
notebook that we're working on so those
are now available to us it helps to have
some data to work with and we have here
going to create a path and a test path
and we'll go ahead and let's just
highlight this whole path and you can
always post a note either down below in
the YouTube video or you can post a note
simply learn comm and ask for this path
if you're not quite picking it up but it
is over here at the UCI edu on there set
up and it's in their archive so it's
archived on ICS UCI dot edu /ml for
machine learning / machine - learning -
databases slash adult that's quite a
mouthful and in this case we have adult
data an adult test but let's go and just
take a look at that let me just paste
that right in there to our browser
window and here's our adult data and if
I click on there it's gonna come down as
a download I'm gonna go ahead and open
it as a text my notepad and the guys in
the back we're kind enough to look up to
find out what the actual columns were in
this coming across so let me do and take
that - pull that information it doesn't
matter where I put it before below
because these are just variables but we
can see here that we have age work class
final WGT I'm guessing that's final look
that up in just second see what that
matches in fact let's pull that up I
just put them next to each other so we
can kind of see we got here so we have
age we have our working class state gov
maybe final wage 77 516 education of
bachelors education number 13 marital
never married admin clerical
relationship not in family so on and so
on so it goes all the way across here so
we've pulled out this information native
country label etc well go ahead and run
this and so now we've loaded all our
different paths and this path by the way
this is the same columns on here so I
don't need to create a separate columns
on the adul
test and once we've run this we've set
those variables let's go ahead and pull
that data in and to do that we'll use
pandas and will create a DF train a DF
test each one's gonna have our PD for
pandas read CSV you'll have our path we
put in there our path test the first one
went ahead and skip initial space true
names columns
there's our columns in their index
column equals false there's no index
column on the second one if we went back
into here and we open up adult tests let
me just go ahead and open that up pad
you'll see there's an actual row up here
we want to skip one by three cross
validator with all the same data in it
so we're looking at the same data in
there and here we're gonna go ahead and
bring in our data and then once you
bring it in it's always nice to see what
kind of shape your data is in and of
course when we talk about shape we're
talking about how many rows and columns
not whether it's been lifting weights we
can see here we have each one has 15
columns and that goes with our columns
right here if we counted them there's
gonna be 15 and the first data set has
32,000 561 rows where the second one has
16,000 281 rows it's also good to see
just how the data came in so we'll use
the pandas d-types we'll run that and
you can see here where age came in as an
integer integer 64 working class is an
object which makes sense and then we
have our fnl WGT the education is
objects or well this is an integer
integer object so on all the way down if
we flash back to the data we look at the
last column it's less than or equal to
50 K and if we scroll down enough we'll
see it's also greater than or equal to
50 K so we'd like to kind of give that
its own special set up on that label so
on that feature we're gonna set the
label equal to if it's less than or
equal to 50 k is going to be 0 and if
it's greater than or equal to 50 K it's
going to be 1 so it's one or the other
that's always an easy easy thing to read
and then we can take this and we go DF
trained label equals label item for item
and DF trained label and this just loops
through all the labels there's a lot of
ways we can do this pandas this it might
be actually kind of a slower way there's
a way to do just that
set up and do the logic within the
setup instead of doing a loop but for
this this thing will work fine we're not
dealing with a lot of data you know it's
a large data set it's not that big of a
data set as data goes and we also want
to do it for our test data I didn't
really mention that we created to date
we're looking at two different data sets
one we're going to train the data and
then we're gonna take it and run the
test data to see if it works
so we have our two different data sets
and we didn't catch it off the bat if
you were pulling up this you're gonna
pull up one the this is the training set
and if we go back in here and open up
the test set let me just go back and do
that adult test one of the things that
we didn't notice that you'll want to
pull up is at the end there's a period
so we're pre processing our data we want
to make sure that we include that period
in every line on the second setup so I
go back to my Jupiter notebook I've got
to have a label T which is less than or
equal to 50 K period or greater than
equal to 50 K period for one otherwise
it's doing the exact same thing we're
gonna change the DF train label on the
DF test label to zero or one we'll just
run that we'll go ahead and print the DF
train label value counts and the DF test
label value counts this is always a good
idea cuz we want to know is there any
weird stuff going on there if there's no
value stuff like that this will turn up
on that set up and we can see here we
have zeros how many zeros how many ones
and so on on there just a quick view of
the data that we're going through and if
we go back up here go ahead and print
the Train D types again and we run that
you could actually run it up there and
give you the new answer it's just loaded
this information we now see it's an
integer and if you go back up here it
was an object so that makes life a
little easier as far as what we're doing
with this now at this point we're going
to look at the data and we can see we
have a lot of numbers and we have a lot
of categories in here so categories
would be the United States mail never
married versus seven we can also see
that when we looked at this we have our
integers we have our objects working
class so the next thing we want to do on
there is we want to go ahead and take
that we have integers and the objects
and we want to bring that down here we
want to create those categories in a way
that the computer
can see them and we'll start with our
continuous features like age we can see
age integer fnl WGT is an integer
capital gain is an integer educational
number there's our educational numbers
and integer and so on so if we're gonna
have these as continuous features where
they're an integer we also need to make
a list of the categorical features we
want to work with such as working class
education marital occupation
relationship race sex and native country
and again these are all objects so that
makes sense and when we flip back over
to the data we can see here we're
actually looking at knighted states if
we continue down we find another one
a lot of United States on this
particular one that's getting worried
there for a second that we only had
United States and it was a very biased
census which it probably is for wherever
it came from and of course bachelors
associate vocational some college so you
see this is more categorical versus an
actual number so now we have our
categorical and we have our continuous
features and this is just the list of
these so let's go ahead and run that and
load that list in there so we can now
start manipulating our data with it now
we get our first line of tensor flow
code which is exciting and we're going
to create a variable continuous features
and what we're doing in here is we're
going to go into TF feature columns so
we have the feature columns we're gonna
set those up numeric columns K for K in
continual features so this is gonna go
in here and says each one of these is a
continual feature and we're gonna feed
that into the future column not very
exciting on the output because we're
just creating this variable here letting
I know what columns are what then we're
going to create a relationship set up so
we have continuous features and then we
have a relationship and again we're
doing TF but in this case we use feature
column so just like this one we're
telling it feature column and now we do
categorical column with vocabulary list
so it's one of the things we can do with
tensorflow and we're gonna feed it one
we have relationship and so we're just
drilling down to the relationship column
and these are the options they had so
this is going to be the vocabulary
attached to this column and we'll go
ahead and run that so we load up our
relationship and then we're gonna do one
more way of loading
and this one we're gonna do categorical
features and so in categorical features
we're gonna do TF feature column there's
a command we've already seen before and
it's gonna be categorical column with
hash bucket we're going to create
buckets in this case for K and
categorical features so it's gonna
create a bucket for each one of these
categorical features and the bucket size
is 1000 so we're looking at we've
actually kind of repeated something
because relationship is also in the
bucket set up on there but we want to
show you three major ways of loading in
your different features one is our
features that we know where it's going
to be a number so our continuous
features then we can send it as a
relationship in this case we actually
created a vocabulary husband not in
family very clear vocabulary on there
and then we also are loading just
general categories into buckets you can
set different bucket settings in here we
went ahead and just went with a thousand
so pretty much everything since there's
not a huge number of categories each one
gets their own kind of bucket set up in
there and as far as the initial set up
we need to go ahead and create a model
so this is where it starts to come
together we've as far as the pre set up
we have our TF we have an estimator
we're gonna do linear classifier on the
estimator in class is equals to so we
know there's only two classes we're
looking at we have ongoing trained
feature columns and then we have our
different we have a categorical features
plus continuous features so this
basically creates our model what data is
going in and we'll go ahead and run this
and you can see here that it gives us a
little information that we had our
tensor flow using default config you can
change a lot of defaults you can change
as far as the model directory random
seed saving summary check points there's
all kinds of things you can go in here
and set up rewrite options keep
checkpoint mix etc this point the model
hasn't done anything all we've done is
create the model so let's just do a real
quick rehash of what we've done so far
well we started off with as we grabbed
some data in this case an adult and
adult tests we have a training data set
and a test data set we set the columns
up we took a very short brief
exploration of the data
shape as far as what we're working with
we changed our label around a little bit
so that the label makes a little bit
more sense of 0-1 instead of for the
Machine it's easier to spit out a 0 or a
1 we can look up here we double check to
make sure we how many zeros and ones we
have double check our data make sure
it's integers 64 nothing weirds going on
and then we like to three different ways
that we can kind of label the data as
far as the way we're gonna read it we
have our continuous features and a
categorical features here's a
relationship which is one of them we
went ahead and created our model we did
not put the relationship in here what
you can do you can actually maybe take
it out of categorical and then have it
sewn on here instead of having
categorical features and continuous
features and so on so we've created our
setup for our model the next thing we
need to do is we need to go ahead and
create a function letting it know how to
read the data into our model how are we
gonna train it let's go ahead and create
two variables the first one is going to
be features this is just all the
features that are in there and then the
second one is gonna be our label and
this is basically we're looking at all
the different information we can put
into it and then is that person based on
that information going to make lesson or
greater than 50 K that's what that comes
down to now the next part the definition
we're going to create has a lot in it
and we're going to feed this definition
into our model training so there's a lot
of stuff that goes on here first we'll
call it get input and function def get
input function we have our data set
number of epochs equals none in batch
equals 128 shuffle equals true so we're
running this and this is going to return
a TF estimator inputs pandas input
function and in this case is going to be
x equals our PD data frame K data set K
values for K and features Y is PD series
data set label values batch size equals
in batch number of epochs equals number
of epochs shuffle equals shuffle so in
here we're passing in the number of
epochs we're not too worried about we're
gonna just go once through the data X
there's a lot of data in there we don't
need to rerun it epochs is how many
times do you cover all the data and then
how many
groups have dated do you pull in a batch
at a time so we're only going to look at
128 do the reverse propagation like we
talked about and then it'll go to the
next batch and the next batch in the
next batch and it shuffles them so
shuffle means that we're randomly
picking where they're coming from again
we're only doing we're not too worried
about the number of epochs for this
particular model depending on how much
data you have and depending what you're
running depends on how many epochs you
need to run and there's a lot of rules
and how many epochs you need to run one
of them is if your training data and
your testing data because you'll check
your testing data against your training
data if your testing data starts having
a better results in your training data
that means you're no longer fitting
towards the data but you're fitting to
the answer so it's kind of these little
weird things you start to on here and
tensorflow is really cool because it
actually checks a lot of that for you
but we're just gonna set number of
epochs equal to zero and then we have
our data set going in so we're creating
our get function how do we get the data
into training our model and we'll go
ahead and run that so now we have our
data function and now it knows where the
data is coming from so we need to go
ahead and train it and that's simply we
take our model we created way up here as
we take the model there we've told it
what columns is going to pull in so it
knows what columns it's looking at know
what the definition where it's going to
get the information from so now we want
to go ahead and train it and here's our
input function equals in this case get
input function and here we tell it that
our data set is DF train number of
epochs equals none which has already
automatically set up there and batch
equals 128 which is what we have up here
shuffle equals false and we're gonna do
1000 steps so we're actually gonna go
through 128 batches but we're gonna do
that a thousand times and we'll go ahead
and run this and I just ran an update so
it's gonna be give me some warnings
because of that update and then we're
back here and I still going to construct
pipelines use TF data module not a big
problem we let it go ahead and run all
the way through one here it takes in
just a moment there we go there's our
thousand coming out and as you can see
here here's a check points for 1,000
ongoing training a thousand and one
global steps this is this all the
reverse propagation going on that's what
we're doing here one of the things we
didn't cover is we do it in small
increments so it's not all done like one
error goes all the way back you do only
do a part of that error in each one it
sends back a little piece and so they
slowly adjust your different weights
going all the way back and then if
you're gonna train your model we want to
know how it did so we're gonna do model
evaluate and our input function equals
Miriam put function up here that we
created up here we're gonna take this
input function and instead of the data
set that's coming in we put in the data
set here for training where's our
training input train there we go DF
underscore train now we're gonna go
ahead and evaluate and here it is get
input function test so we're going to
test the data out number of epochs one
we don't need to rerun it more than once
per batch 128 so on shuffle and steps of
thousand so we're gonna go ahead
evaluate this let's just see how good
our test data did how good our model was
programmed on our training data and how
it evaluates on the test we can see it
going on down here where it's got the
evaluating graph was finalized let me
just highlight that ongoing model
checkpoint tensorflow running local an
it evaluate 100 out of a thousand and so
on and once it gets to the end we get a
nice output here we have an accuracy in
this case of 0.79 with a baseline of
0.76 so now we've created a model let's
go ahead and tweak it a little bit so we
have our accuracy up here what we're
gonna do is we're gonna look at age and
let's just go ahead and create a new
square value for age and the reason we
want to look into the square value of
age is we know that if you really look
through the data you'll find that as a
young person the age keeps increasing as
you get close to retirement it begins to
decrease so we square the value of age
and that's very data specific when we're
looking at data you'll find that any
kind of data that has that kind of like
uptick and down tick by squaring it or
square rooting it you can get some very
different results and so we're gonna go
ahead and square our age and this is
kind of it's interesting it's at this
point even at the beginning of this
we're focused on deep learning and on
tensorflow but before I would begin even
looking at any of this I would have
probably run some
kind of heat map or some kind of
evaluation in our or SK learn and Python
to find out the correlation between
different features to see just how well
they correlate to each other and there
certainly are some wonderful tools for
that because sometimes you can just mark
off some features and other features you
bring in but for the deep learning we
can see how we can just dump it all in
there and let it sort it out itself now
we're going to just write a quick little
function here to take the square
variable in this case we have DFTD FTE
this is our training and your test
variable and the variable age coming in
and we just want to go ahead and create
a new under DFT and the new is going to
be the variable name and if we put in
there which will be age so let's load
this here's our functions now loaded and
certainly we could have just done that
as a line of code but you start to get
the feeling that when you build these
functions you might use it you can now
use this function if you had a number of
different features that had this kind of
quality to them and we have our DF train
new so we're gonna create a new training
and a new test and it's gonna equal the
square variable DF train or DF test and
the variable name is age let's just go
ahead and run that and so now we have
our new our DF train new and DF test new
and just like we did before this is
double check the shape of our data and
make sure it all matches and when we
look at the output here really what's
important is that each one of these has
16 features in it we want to make sure
we're not getting something weird on
there and our training set has 32,000
561 rows in it and this one has just
over 16,000 in there and everything's
pretty much the same except that in our
continuous features new we now have the
new call and we put in there so we need
to change that and we have our
continuous features new down here which
we're gonna load up with our TF feature
column numerical this would all look
familiar because we just did this and so
we're gonna load that up with the new
being the new value in there let's go
ahead and run that and we'll create a
model that will call it model 1 and this
is the same that we did before except
now we have our continuous features new
in here so here's our new model in this
case model 1 instead of model we're
gonna build that model right there
now we haven't trained it all we've done
is told it where to get the data and how
to get the data and what features are
coming in we haven't actually told that
everything on the features coming in
because we still need to also build our
full arm get input functions
where's the input coming from so we
built the model with the features in it
and now we need to go ahead and create
our get input function this is the same
as before but you'll see we now have it
with the data set coming in is going to
be the same data set up here and so if
we scroll a little bit to the right we
should see the new and there it is sure
enough there's our new on the right and
so let's go ahead and run that now we've
defined our model we defined where the
information is coming from and again you
can go back and review the first part
because this is identical that we did
before except now we have new as the
column for the age and we'll go ahead
and do our model 1 and let's go ahead
and train it there's our input function
and get input function that we defined
up here DF train is gonna be the same
and everything else is going to be the
same let's go ahead and run that and it
should go through here and run the
tensor info coming in and it's gonna go
through in this case where we have steps
one thousand shuffling so it's gonna go
randomly 128 per batch and then the
epochs is automatic we're not worried
about that today so now we have a
trained tensor flow model and with our
new model just like we did before we
want to go ahead and evaluate it so it's
the same setup we had before with our
same get input function with our DF test
new in here coming in so there's our new
data coming in this is really common
when you're doing these models you make
little tiny tweaks to see if you can
improve it one of the best articles I
read recently was you build your model
to fail you want a running model so you
actually have something to compare
against and then you continually tweak
it till you get a better accuracy now I
don't expect the accuracy necessarily to
get better on this because of the way we
partition the data we can see here we
now have an accuracy of 0.76 which is a
little bit over the baseline and it's
about what I would have expected it to
be kind of the same the reason is
because we split the data at the 50 the
people making over 50k and those making
less and so the age factor shouldn't be
a huge factor it would be if we were
looking at more discreet buckets like 40
to 50 50 to 60 60 to 70 creep buckets
but in this I didn't really expect it to
go up that much fact we could probably
run it a dozen times which may be very
bad data science and we see we actually
had a slightly better one up here but
our baseline accuracy was 0.76 we come
down here we still see
our accuracy baseline 0.763 that didn't
really change and you know the accuracy
didn't really go up that much I could
hit the Run button a few times I would
probably up beat the one above it's not
a big change but that's alright this is
how we learned is how we go through and
figure out what's going to work with our
data and what's not what's going to
improve the quality of our data so we
have a better prediction and what's not
and we can now go ahead and utilize this
model this is where it gets exciting
when you're actually working with
somebody or with your clients and you
come in and say okay here's my
predictions we're gonna take a look
create a list and we're going to use
model one and we're gonna predict and
our input function is get input function
DF test new again this probably doesn't
make too big of a difference but we'll
go ahead and stick with the new data we
created number of epochs one batch 128
so all this should look pretty familiar
but we're running the prediction so
we're gonna load all our predictions
into the predictions and let's go ahead
and run that and you'll see it go
through the tensor flow setup and so
it's running done running local ops and
then let's just go ahead and print the
DF test new eye locations zero so a row
zero and we're going to look at the
predictions also for the same location
zero let's go ahead and run that and we
can see here that we have age 25 for
class private it has all the information
coming in for that individual and then
it comes down here we go ahead and get
our prediction and in this particular
there's our label 0 and then we come
down here and we see takes a little bit
for the setup to look up but there's our
array which also returns a 0 and it has
information for us on their
probabilities logistics on here so you
can see all kinds of additional
information you can pull from this
likewise we could do it for position 3
let me go ahead and run that what's kind
of nice about this is you can now see
here's label 1 and here's our logistics
output and again at the kind of hunt for
a little bit in this particular set up
but here's the output array and there's
r1 and they match label 1 1 so we
predicted for the very first ones
location 0 that it's going to be a 0 and
the label it's going to make under
50,000 and the individual in to working
class private whatever setup on here
capital gain capital S loss etc came up
as 1 meaning they're gonna make over
50,000 so we covered a lot I mean this
is the basics and you can see is
dig deeper when you look at some of this
code let me just go back up here we're
way back up here at the very top a
little too far overshot so you start
working in here we have one defining
your features and at this point we
didn't show this but I would probably
use either Python or R to show a
relationship correlation because they
have some really easy packages in there
to pull that up so you can see what
features are really connected and how
they're connected and then we showed you
different features like we have ones
that are integers and then we have ones
like sex that are objects we are 0-1
you're male or female you're same thing
with a race probably have just two maybe
16 different races listed there Anisa
tees things like that native country
again that's you don't have like
infinite number of native countries you
just have a handful so we look at this
we have our features we looked at that
we have our continuous features like age
which is a number or an in this case an
integer and education number how many
years and so on along with your race
your sex your relationship which are
just very abbreviated categorical data
as we looked at that we went in there
and we showed you how to where was it
here we go back up here so we create our
model the model hat knows what
categories are coming in it's really
important and this is probably the one
of the more complicated parts of this is
our input function and this input
function is so important so I want to
just rehash the input function for that
reason this lets us know how we're
pulling the data it lets us know if
we're going to go through all the data
20 times or we're gonna let the or we're
just gonna let tensor flow itself keep
going until the training model reaches a
point that point is based on with what
they call bias you can become biased on
your training data and so it hits a
certain point where it becomes overly
biased to just that data then it doesn't
really work really good in the outside
world you start losing want to keep it
generic but as close as possible to the
right answer so generic answers for a
huge amount of data and then we have our
batch size are we going to shuffle it
which we did and then also our estimator
inputs so your estimator function here
and then of course where the actual data
is coming from so you can see all this
is in
get input function that's where a lot of
the work comes in putting this together
and then we train our model that's
pretty straightforward once you have
your input function and all your set up
training the model is quick and then we
go ahead and evaluate and then we can go
ahead and create a predict and then you
know look at our predictions and how
they work on individuals so it's pretty
gives you a whole roundabout setup on
here and how this is set up and how it's
working certainly there are a lot more
things you can do with tensorflow
this is the basic tensorflow and it's
always developing so it's exciting this
isn't gonna be the most exciting fields
right now because it is really in an
infant stage and just exploding in the
market so with that we'll go ahead and
wrap it up I want to thank you for
joining us today again my name is
Richard Kirchner with the simply learned
team for more information visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor up and get
certified click here